[Music]
lords of the ring
trilogy if you see it back-to-back
watching the lord of the rings trilogy
all in one sitting
i mean i like every flavor of
baskin-robbins too but i don't get a
scoop of every single one of them when i
go in
very often
hey whoa michael poor speakerphone
etiquette number one you reached all the
way over someone to put
their phone on speaker and second you
didn't immediately tell the person you'd
put them on speakerphone
sure jim's trying to be a smart ass here
but there are rules also before he
started the problem what makes jim so
sure that michael is not truly in danger
enough to make this an office-wide joke
it's almost like everyone on this show
is an [ __ ] okay
i burned my foot very badly on my
foreman grill
you burned your foot on a foreman grill
jim repeats something another character
says and then looks knowingly into the
camera cliche
today i got up i stepped onto the grill
and i clamped down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that actually nothing
i will accept all entries is worth it in
the pursuit of bacon i once swallowed
half a toothpick because i was so
anxious to eat a bacon-wrapped scallop
the real sin here is the control bacon
has over us tell ryan to bring toilet
paper
can you tell him that can you hop look
kevin i've tried that there's just some
of it that won't fall off without
getting some toilet paper really
up on in wait i may have misunderstood
poo pooing the man who is coming to
rescue you it's broken right he can't
watching someone in need of help instead
of [ __ ] going down there and helping
him yourself
i know fans give dwight a lot of but we
should all be in agreement that there
aren't enough apples at the grocery
store to accurately convey what a group
of [ __ ] this group is
holding your home showcase it anywhere
called the icebox using a highlighter to
circle words instead of just
highlighting them considering michael is
behind his desk why are scratches
leaning against this wall i mean it's a
nice place if you want them in the shot
but a stupid place if the character is
actually making human choices
we clearly see they use windows machines
here and windows limits their folder
names to 255 characters considering
they're over 150 instances of dwight
that would take up 900 characters
plus the spaces would be another 150
plus you've still got the untitled
folder at the front
and that's a total of 24 minutes and 13
seconds of my life i just wasted
figuring that out
i know this russian website where you
can download songs for two cents a piece
[Laughter]
paying for music
[Laughter]
downloading songs oh this show man
okay see you later pan
bam i agree it's weird movie to bring up
however some reviews did say that the
only way to enjoy joe wright's pan would
be if you had recently suffered a
concussion
tell me before i come there title of my
sex tape
maybe men's restrooms connected to the
break room are typical but they
shouldn't be
have you ever been in a men's bathroom
or near one i'm not even sure two rooms
away is far enough from the stench and
or to be eating a cheese stick
also eating string cheese without
honoring the string part around age 12 i
just started going for it
oh well then ascend for 12 year old you
too ryan who was supposed to be dead
saving private ryan haters you people
are jerks an objectively true statement
accidentally makes it into the script
philadelphia
aids confusing joe versus the volcano
with philadelphia
where's that splash i really should bone
up in my knowledge of martin short films
he grew into a man overnight a rare
disability still works
knowing enough about big to know the
plot but still somehow thinking the
piano scene was from philadelphia
a crossword puzzle stan lee seriously
are you learning nothing here
if he's doing a crossword puzzle he's
probably learning quite a bit i'm sure
he's learned that the dog from the thin
man is named asta
user female sheep and that the tree
people from the hobbit wars are known as
ants
or what's that hobbit trek sorry i'm
late somebody parked in the handicapped
parking space
michael called this meeting 20 minutes
ago okay 20 minutes
conference room everybody's in there so
how is he motivated enough to print out
pictures of disabled people call a guy
in a wheelchair at moment's notice who
could rush down here in no time and
basically get all of this together in
20 minutes and now he sets the crutches
here
which is also in the shot what an
amazingly convenient coincidence
i ground up four extra strength aspirin
and put them in michael's pudding
drugging your boss without explicit
consent or really drugging anyone
oh okay i think we need to take him to
the hospital pretty sure jim should have
done that after billy merchant said
dwight probably had a concussion
he needs to go right now and you're his
emergency contact i think you should go
with him
we might be aware of angela's
relationship with dwight and why she
would know this information but no one
else in the office should be aware
so no one questions this oh pam you're
adorable oh
my goodness come here oh
hugs there really weren't enough pam and
dwight moments like this
fisher and wilson play great off each
other as foes but also as friends
at least we have this moment shotgun you
don't think you should sit in the back
but dwight
the rules of shotgun are very simple and
very clear much has been made of the
office's documentary style where they
cut to these interviews for easy jokes
but i want to know how this happened
you're telling me that they went to the
hospital did all the tests came back
then interviewed michael in his office
again and some jerkface was like hey you
called shotgun earlier when we were all
going to the hospital tell us about
shotgun it'll be really interesting for
this 487 hour documentary about a paper
company
the first person to shout shotgun when
you're within the side of the car gets
the front seat
that's how the game's played there are
no exceptions for someone with a
concussion
maybe not but jim didn't say dwight
should ride in the front seat he said
you don't think you should sit in the
back with dwight so get in the back seat
with your friend and make sure he isn't
falling asleep or
smelling colors flip phones okay mr
schrute inhale with me
on three speaking of three this
documentary crew brought
three full camera rigs and crew to this
hospital
outside the door inside this room with
the tech and on the other side of the
hallway not to mention they still have
at least one camera person and crew back
at the office
who financed this documentary and when
can i pitch them something
sir stop that stop pretty sure we send
this every time but the more office
episodes i watch the more confused i am
as to how michael not only has a job but
functions in the real world at this
point michael is written as a
pre-existing pile of moronic cellular
matter
desperately clinging to sentience
the hideousness of that foot will haunt
my dreams forever
could you come get me uh i have to stay
here and answer the phone
i seem to have fallen down a cliff i'm
still alive but i'm very badly injured
please stop popping my cast salty i'm
sitting
here with the bloody stump of a foot
just a flesh wound hmm
you like candy i want an everlasting
gobstopper
imagine if you had left stevie wonder on
the floor of that bathroom instead of me
oh we wouldn't we love stevie wonder
i drive a dodge stratus i found the
pudding cups you wanted at a gas station
in carbondale
i bet that snack pack's pretty good i
just want to say goodbye okay
the most beautiful thing in the world
come here come here man